bonjour jean marc bonjour iv heureux de
vous retrouver ce matin sur le plateau
d' air thé france alors ces prix de
l'essence soulève deux questions d'abord
pourquoi ces nouvelles hausses et
ensuite que peut faire le gouvernement
pour calmer les prix a écouté les
semaines se suivent et se ressemblent
puisque cette semaine vous le disiez les
prix de l'essence ont touché les deux
euros pratiquement du litre dans
certains centres villes alors c'est une
moyenne sur la france entière le gazole
est à peu près en moyenne à 67 le
sans-plomb dépasse les 1 64 bon ça veut
dire concrètement qu on a pris deux
centimes par litre dans la semaine si ça
continue un script mais bien faites le
calcul on partir en vacances l'été
prochain avec un carburant à 2,030 ça
risque quand même d'être chaud c'est
déjà chaud encore beaucoup de familles
alors les explications sont toujours les
mêmes parce que le prix des carburants
dépend de l'offre et de la demande de
pétrole premier point avec la quatrième
vague de variants au micron l'activité
économique avait fléchi un petit peu en
descend de la demande de pétrole s'était
ralentie et là bas tout est reparti avec
le recul du variant et ça dans le monde
entier alors vous voyez bien la
circulation automobile aujourd'hui ce
matin-même notamment à paris est re
devenu pratiquement normale deuxième
fois vous avez des pays producteurs qui
spéculent un peu mais vous avez aussi
des régions pétrolières qui sont un peu
bousculé ça vous a pas échappé les
risques géopolitiques
donc les robinets à pétrole sont menacés
les tensions sur la frontière entre
l'ukraine la russie où il ya beaucoup
d'enjeux sur le gaz la situation entre
l'arabie saoudite le yémen la sécurité
n'est pas assurée or nous sommes là dans
des grandes régions pétrolières enfin
j'ajouterai un troisième point c'est que
il fait froid dans tout l'hémisphère
nord donc on consomme beaucoup d'énergie
et vous avez certains pays producteurs
qui retiennent un peu leur niveau de
production leur niveau de livraisons
parce qu'ils font de l'argent les pays
producteurs ont besoin de reconstituer
leur cagnotte parce qu'ils n'ont pas
vendu beaucoup de pétrole pendant toute
cette période de pandémie tous ces
facteurs font monter le prix du brut et
sans tomber dans le pessimisme beaucoup
d'économistes pensent que ça va
continuer les banques américaines voient
le brut à plus de 100 dollars le baril
l'été prochain ça mettrait le litre
d'essence à 2,030 de 0,48 jean-marc que
peut faire le gouvernement va le
gouvernement il peut pas obliger les
pays producteurs de pétrole à produire
plus le fond c'est la décision des pays
producteurs et l'occident un peu de
moyens de pression pour qu'ils ouvrent
les vannes en plus l'intérêt des pays
producteurs c'est là où ces housses et
perverse et de vendre leur pétrole le
plus cher possible et en vendre le moins
possible pour que ça dure longtemps la
rente pétrolière donc le gouvernement ne
peut rien faire pour réguler la
production en revanche il pourrait
intervenir au niveau des différentes
étapes du raffinage par exemple ou de la
distribution mais c'est risquer tout ça
il peut raboter les marges mais les
pétroliers vont dire qu'il n'y a pas de
marge ils ne peuvent ils ne pourront pas
assez large et pourront pas investir
d'ailleurs total aujourd'hui a sorti un
communiqué disant qu'il allait investir
massivement à nouveau dans les énergies
naturelles c'est de bonne guerre ça tout
ça de cette communication dans la
distribution les marges sont très
réduites michel edouard leclerc le dit
souvent dans les hypermarchés par
exemple faux pas de marges qui
l'utilisent les ventes de carburants
comme produits d'appel alors le
gouvernement qu'est ce qui pourrait
faire il pourrait évidemment réduire les
taxes sur les carburants parce que dans
1 litre d'essence on paye plus de la
moitié taxe à peu près 60% mais
franchement réduire les taxes sur
l'essence ça serait suicidaire alors et
un certain nombre de responsables
politiques qui le demande baisse de tva
mais ils disent pas par quoi ils vont la
remplacer au niveau des budgets le
gouvernement perdra une grande partie de
ses recettes fiscales qui sont
aujourd'hui plus importante que celle de
l'impôt sur le revenu alors le
gouvernement peut toujours soulager la
facture en distribuant de l'argent des
chèques carburant des chaque énergie des
primes à l'électricité et ça ça coûte un
prix exorbitant et ça n'empêche pas le
prix du brut de monter en 2021 on a du
kram et pour reprendre l'expression
d'une candidate à la présidence de
répliques près de 30 milliards d'euros
pour calmer la grogne des automobilistes
on va sans doute continuer du moins
jusqu'à la présidentielle alors il y
aurait une solution plus durable oui ce
serait de dépenser tout cet argent pour
accélérer le passage à l'électrique
investir dans les voitures les batteries
et les stations de recharge qui sont
très rares et puis relancer la
production d'électricité nucléaire mais
on voit pas dans les programmes
présidentiels de l'affirmation d'une
ambition très forte de ce point de vue
là je sais pas si vous avez remarqué
tout le monde est très frileux je suis
d'ailleurs très frappés du silence d'une
partie de la gauche française et
notamment des écologistes sur cette
question on du prix de l'essence la
hausse des carburants touche d'abord les
populations assez défavorisés ceux qui
habitent la campagne qui sont obligés
d'utiliser leur bagnole pour travailler
dans les petites villes ils paient plein
pot et bien sûr ce point là les
écologistes n'ont pas de solution sauf à
dissuader les gens d'utiliser leur
voiture la belle affaire parce qu un
pétrole cher leur donne raison
finalement un pétrole cher si l'arrêt de
mort de l'automobile donc ils sont assez
contents mais ils n'ont rien pour la
remplacer peut-être l'électrique mais
comme l'électrique et nucléaire et qui
sont contre le nucléaire disent rien
mais la gauche n'est pas plus brillante
1 la campagne de la primaire n'a pas dit
un mot sur le prix de l'essence la
parler de l'écriture inclusive elle a
parlé des violences faites aux femmes
mais tu prix de l'essence non la gauche
et l'ensemble de la classe politique
préfère parler du risque d'inflation
généralisée et des pertes de pouvoir
d'achat qui sera à côté du sujet
beaucoup d'analystes explique que cette
remontée des prix du carburant peut
relancer l'inflation généralisée
cognitifs légers d'édition à côté du
sujet et se trempe les hausses de prix
auquel on assiste à gérer sur très
segmenté très localisés les carburants
le pétrole le gaz l'électricité parce
que son prix dépend du fioul et du gaz
mais vous avez des produits alimentaires
aussi des composants industriels qui
sont bloqués en asie tout ça est très
immobilier un peu mais mais mais pour le
reste il n'y a pas de contamination aux
autres produits et notamment aux
salaires il ya assez peu de hausses de
salaires les syndicats ne sont pas
vindicatif sur les salaires les seules
hausses de salaire ont lieu dans les
secteurs en tension avec des forte
productivité dans digital dans le
e-commerce cela dit on arrive en
campagne présidentielle on peut avoir un
mouvement revendicatif générale à la
hausse un mouvement de rattrapage mais
on voit pas un phénomène de contagion en
europe comme aux états unis qui sont
plus menacés que nous par l'inflation
mais ça restera limitée
l'économie est dominée aujourd'hui par
la croissance par l'investissement et
par l'emploi on le voit dans tous les
indicateurs ils sont orientés ouverte
donc l'économie génère du travail et de
la richesse ça n'est pas un passionné ça
à d'autres défauts mais ce n'est pas
infléchi merci beaucoup jean marc lito
écoute jean marc sylvestre c'est tous
les mercredis matin dans la matinale de
rtl france
[Musique]